çok
güzel geldiniz
bir
şekilde o
[Müzik]
bu olması için de az önce edilmesinin
olduğu eserlerin ekledim kısaca temiz
enerji
açıklaması bu
dünyamızın enerji kıyafetin yeşilde
artmakta ve güneş
enerji
kaynaklarımız ve
en
son değerli iplerden bir sorunla yüzyüze
kalıyoruz karbon herkesi bizi Mutlu
Yaşam içinde kullandığımız
enerji kaynaklarının arasında bıraktı
karbonlu etkisi çıkacak Bunlar da
etkinleştirilir oluyor ve temiz enerji
kaynaklarının kullanımı sol ölçüleri ve
atıp için ürünleri arasında
dışında enerji kaynağının türüne göre
atıp ürünleri bitti enerji kaynağına
göre azdır ya da hiç yoktur
iklim değişikliği ile mücadele ederken
karşımıza 1985'te
bu
ve en son Paris Anlaşması yapıldı mı
[Müzik]
ve
akaryakıt kaynak kullanımının
azaltılması gerekir Elif bunu da bir
bakayım
elektrikli arabalar geliyor O
2018'den itibaren olarak
devlete çalışıyoruz işte olmaz olmaz
bırakıyoruz ve orman yangınları oluyor
bu
ne yapabiliriz ki
[Müzik]
o kimse teslim olmaya karar ver ya
Ya
bırak Reklam gibi reklam
hayaliniz bu hayali gerçekleştirmek
gerçekten değer verdim Hala biliyoruz O
[Müzik]
mi Evet
bu
söz konusu
olduğu zaman ormanların korunması da
bizim için Ekstra
olması gerekiyor
wth
[Müzik]
markası ne
he he çekme ait gideceğiz Sunal güzellik
yani bir Kurtuluş saldım
yapışması gerekiyor çünkü ormanlar bu
iyi varlıklarımız Bunları hep aynı
şekilde o
Evet Ee bak değil bu
Yılmaz var
o Türkiye'nin ilk ve tek tarifimiz var
dünyada sadece
262d sadece büyük testlerde olan bir
belge Bu belgelerin
olması gereken o
[Müzik]
bu
olarak uyacaklar vardı yeterli kablolar
mı yok onun altına soktu terlikler yok
seyret olmadığını da erkekler almaya
başlıyoruz babam hayali
[Müzik]
sadece o
ben
[Müzik]
kendimi yetiştirmek istiyorum
o yüzden o
[Müzik]
[Alkış]